angefangen hat alles anfang märz in der
bahn
da hat viktoria gemerkt dass sich etwas
verändert hat
skeptische blicke von fremden fahrgäste
die aufstehen und in ein anderes abteil
gehen zuerst gedacht dass ich mir das
ein bilder hab dann wirklich beobachtet
dass die leute mit zuerst ins gesicht
geguckt haben und sich dann weg gesetzt
haben und bin dann drei personen
hinterher gelaufen um sicher zu gehen ob
es nicht vielleicht ausgestiegen sind
die personen haben sich aber in vierer-
oder ins fahrradabteil gesetzt viktoria
kurve ist deutsche ihre eltern kamen
schon lange vor ihrer geburt nach
deutschland vorurteile wegen ihres
aussehens kennt sie bereits als nach dem
chor ohne ausbruch in china auch in
deutschland erste fälle auftreten häufen
sich jedoch die vorkommnisse mitten im
herzen des liberalen berlins schlägt er
offener hass entgegen
ein mann ruft ihr zu man solle sie mit
desinfektionsmittel einsprühen ich hab
das gefühl seitdem ich gedruckter oder
so ein bisschen kleiner durch die straße
und habe angst vor anfeindungen bis auch
recht zu geben dass wenn mehrere leute
von aber irgendwie stehen das ist
manchmal eine straßenseite wechseln ich
habe das gefühl seit dem homeoffice bin
ich froh das ist nicht mehr auf die
straße gehe weil ich kein muster
angefeindet zu werden und
habe auch das gefühl dass ich von vielen
leuten obwohl ich in berlin lebe ein
freundlich als deutsche wahrgenommen
werde
viktoria suchte das gespräch doch viele
ihrer deutschen freunde wiegelten ab sie
fühlte sich mit ihrem problem nicht
ernst genommen
über facebook hat sie daher kontakt zu
anderen betroffenen in ganz deutschland
aufgebaut seit beginn der pandemie
werden hier fast täglich neue
anfeindungen gegen menschen mit
asiatischem aussehen gemeldet profan ist
chinese und lebt sie victoria in berlin
auch er wurde bereits mehrfach in der
u-bahn rassistisch beleidigt und hat die
übergriffe mit dem telefon gefilmt ein
freund sagte zu mir
das solltest du unbedingt melden ich
setze zwar wenig hoffnung in die polizei
aber ich möchte den leuten zeigen
ich habe diese beweise und lasse mich
nicht zum schweigen bringen
sich mit anderen betroffenen
auszutauschen das hat viktoria kurve wo
am meisten geholfen
deswegen arbeitet sie momentan an einer
website die vernetzungs und
hilfsangebote für betroffene bündelt das
ist glaube ich wichtig dass leute in
zeiten von social distanzen sich
vernetzen können ihre erfahrungen
sichtbar machen können und leute davon
lesen können rassismus wird es in
deutschland vermutlich auch nach der
korona krise geben sagt viktoria kurve
wo doch dass die opfer sich nicht mehr
verloren fühlen müssen
dazu möchte sie beitragen